you get attacked a lot on the internet
yeah okay I gotta ask you about your own
psychology
um how do you not let that break you
mentally
and how do you avoid letting that lead
to a resentment of the groups that
attack you I mean it's so there are a
few sort of practical things that I've
done so for example I would say that
four years ago Twitter was all consuming
Twitter is an ego machine especially the
notifications button right the
notifications button is just people
talking about you all the time in the
normal human tendency as well people
talking about me I gotta see what
they're saying about me which is a
recipe for Insanity so uh my wife
actually said Twitter is making your
life miserable you need to take it off
your phone so Twitter is not on my phone
if I want to log on to Twitter I I have
to go onto my computer and I have to
make the conscious decision to go onto
Twitter and then take a look at what's
going on I could just imagine you like
there's a computer in the basement you
descend into the Czech Twitter that's
pretty much in the darkness if you look
at when I actually tweet it's generally
like in the run up to recording my show
or when I'm prepping for my show later
in the afternoon for example that
doesn't affect you negatively mentally
like put you in a bad mental space not
particularly if it's restricted to sort
of what what's being watched now I will
say that I think the most important
thing is you have to surround yourself
with a group of people who are who you
trust enough to make serious critiques
of you when you're doing something wrong
but also you know that they have your
best interests at heart because the
internet is filled with people who don't
have your best interests at heart who
hate your gods and so you can't really
take those critiques seriously or does
wreck you and the world is also filled
with sycophants right then the the more
successful you become there are a lot of
people who will tell you you're always
doing the right thing I'm very lucky I
got married when I was 24 my office 20.
so she's known me long before I was
famous or wealthy or anything and so
she's a good sounding board I have a
family that's willing to that's willing
to call me out on my [ __ ] as you
talk to yay about I have friends who are
able to do that I I try to have open
lines of communications with people who
I believe have my best interests at
heart but one of these sort of
conditions being friends that when you
see me do something wrong I'd like for
you to let me know that so I can correct
it I don't want to leave that
Impressions out there the sad thing
about the internet just looking at the
critiques you get
I see very few critiques from people
that actually want you to succeed I want
you to grow I mean they're very uh
they're not sophisticated they're just
they're I don't know they're they're
cruel the critiques are just they're
it's not the actual critiques it's just
cruelty and that's that's most of
Twitter I mean as Twitter is a place to
to
to smack and be smacked I mean that's
the anybody who uses Twitter for uh for
an intellectual conversation I think is
uh engaging in category error I use it
to spread love I think yeah you're the
only one you're it's you it's you and no
one else my friend